J'ai eu un travail aujourd'hui, bons chèques et
journal Je vais être un écrivain sérieux
eglee il est passé à autre chose tu ne l'es plus Je
vais devoir tuer cette femme Abele que tu
connais aussi bien que moi chaque maison blanche
devrait avoir un séparé  salle de bain pour l'
aide
péri elle vient de te construire une salle de bain à l'
extérieur tu as bien dit ce qui
me dérange j'écoute j'ai été élevé
par une femme de couleur j'ai vu à quel
point cela peut être simple et complexe j'aimerais
lire quelque chose de  du point de vue de
l'aide c'est un sacré risque à prendre
dans un endroit comme Jackson Mississippi
ces femmes élèvent des enfants blancs mais
elles ne peuvent même pas utiliser les toilettes de nos
maisons j'ai pensé écrire mes
histoires je les lis  vous allez
bien je vais le faire
saviez-vous en grandissant qu'un jour
vous seriez une femme de chambre oui madame j'ai fait avez-vous
déjà rêvé d'être autre chose
attention, non, madame,
mais vous revenez à ce sont des scandales,
ce sont des incendies ici. Lagos suscite des
ennuis.  déjà ici faire une
démonstration ici jusqu'à l'heure du beat'em
Yahoo m'a amené là-dedans et je vais le
finir et c'est un bon coup
toi